Donald Trump has been insisting for a
while that he does not know --left
Parnas Parnas the now indicted henchmen
of Rudy Giuliani who was working on
Donald Trump's behalf in Europe and in
the Ukraine Fiasco Lev Parnas was one of
the people involved along with Igor
Froman in putting the Ukrainian
ambassador to Ukraine Murray Ivanovich
under physical surveillance which is a
bonkers thing for someone indirectly
hired by or hired by the president's
personal attorney to be doing and we
recently had one video released where
Lev Parnas was at a dinner with Donald
Trump and they were talking about taking
out ambassador Murray Ivanovich and now
a second video has been released this
second video is 37 minutes long it's a
private gathering of Republican donors
which took place at Donald Trump's
mar-a-lago Resort apparently on April
20th 2018 lordie there are even more
tapes as James Comey would say Parnas
himself is videotaped at one point
posing with Donald Trump now the
interesting thing about the timing is if
I understand the timing correctly this
second video would actually have been
from an event 10 days before the video
that was released last week or the week
before so this means that when Donald
Trump and Parnas were speaking about
Murray Ivanovich at the dinner in video
number one they had just ten days prior
Bennet this other event together at
mar-a-lago to get a and of course
remember Donald Trump insists he doesn't
know the guy the second video appears to
have been filmed by Igor Froome and he's
the other indicted henchmen of Rudy
Giuliani and in the video partisan Trump
don't have much of a conversation as we
know in the first video they talk about
Murray Ivanovich Ukraine and other
issues in this video they don't seem to
do that now I wish I could tell you that
this is all going to make any kind of
difference but I think most people who
watch this program with any regularity
know none of this stuff is going to make
any difference we heard from Trump
lawyer Alan Dershowitz that as long as
there's some plausible or even not that
plausible quite frankly
interests that can be claimed for an
action that Donald Trump takes the
action is essentially fine
this was the crux of Alan Dershowitz his
argument as an attorney representing
Donald Trump in the Senate impeachment
trial we are coming up on or by the time
you watch this it may have already
happened the impending acquittal of
Donald Trump by Republican senators in a
complete joke of an impeachment trial in
the Senate they lie all the time about
not knowing Parnas it's an obvious lie
Parnas has the receipts it doesn't
matter they no longer even pretend that
what Donald Trump is doing isn't
questionable they are now of the mindset
that if Trump does it effectively it's
okay impeachment holding the president
accountable all of that that would be
trying to undo an election whose results
you didn't like you don't even need to
hear from firsthand witnesses to Trump's
wrongdoing even when you claim for
months you want firsthand witnesses we
are not in a situation where there are
going to be consequences for any of this
we are living in a very disturbing
nightmare that may not end for five more
years even the appearance of misbehavior
by Donald Trump can't be investigated by
some remember the first position was
well you can't indict a sitting
president they moved on to we don't even
think you can investigate a sitting
president imagine that increasingly the
tone and tenor of the defenses are more
and more reminiscent of Richard Nixon's
if the President does it it's not
illegal and that should strike fear into
every single one of us but for Trump's
base it seems to fire them up it seems
to actually excite and titillate them
into agreeing and unquestioningly
repeating if the president can even cite
some completely flaccid and unbelievable
justification in the public interest of
what he does then by debt by its very
nature it's not it's certainly not
illegal
certainly not impeachable there should
not even be a consequence or an
investigation so as far as the videos
from left Parnas we'll see if more
videos are released through left
Parnassus attorney in the end i don't
think it's going to do much unless they
maybe inspire people not to vote for
Trump in 2020 at this point I think even
if you know the so-called PP tapes are
real
if you have a video of krump shooting
someone but like all this cartoonish
stuff I still don't think that the vast
majority of trumps bass reconsiders
whether to support him in 2020 if any of
that stuff even hypothetically existed
hopefully all of this will do one thing
which is inspire people on our side to
get out and vote in November of 2020
that is the one shot we have of removing
the mango menace the tangerine terror I
really hope that Lev Parnas and and now
I'm sort of kidding here but I'm sort of
serious
if Lev Parnas accidentally falls on a
knife six times and accidentally throws
himself off of a balcony I hear those
knives can jump right out at you that
would be a terrible thing I hope that
doesn't happen if people understand what
it is that I'm saying
I hope I'm kidding I'm probably 80%
kidding let's take a quick break I want
to show you some amazing video of Mike
Pence confront confronted by an
emergency room doctor we are also going
to talk about the latest GDP numbers
from 2019 which we now have that are
interesting I have voicemail we have the
bonus show there is still much more to
come today is the primary message that
I'm trying to transmit to you here